uh i don't know if you know this i was i
was married when i was a young when i
was young i was married uh was
no longer married not married anymore
didn't work out
good empathy i feel that silent
uh don't feel bad uh it just didn't work
i was 22 i was 22 when i got married 22
the same age i was when someone asked me
to draw a map of the world and i just
straight up forgot south america
the same that same year that i omitted a
huge continent
that children are aware of
i decided to pledge my life to another
woman you know what i mean another well
to a woman
to a woman one revelation at a time i'm
divorced i'm not yet ready to tell you
i'm a woman
anyway when i look back on my
relationship i realized that there were
a lot of things i could have done better
you know i mean she ended it but you
know i was at fault a little bit that's
right just another late night monologue
where the host examines the role he
played in the decay of his own marriage
yep pretty standard i can feel you like
they did it on camel
but if i may for all i want to give some
advice to all the lovers out there uh
first of all don't call yourself lovers
that's just that's gross like
hey
beth and i are lovers
do you have a spare bedroom
don't do that it's gross but real advice
don't put your partner on a pedestal
that's real that's something i used to
do in my marriage i used to say all
sorts of stupid things to my ex just
like oh you're perfect
you are perf i was a surfer oh you're
perfect
boo boo you're perfect you're an angel
you're a perfect angel
i love you so much i get that one's okay
i love you
but calling someone a perfect angel is
that's no one's a
perfect angel people are flawed
imperfect beings that need to be loved
for who they really are angel if they're
really an angel then your love doesn't
mean anything everybody loves angels
no one's ever been waving a broom around
their house like get out of here angels
people love angels but a real compliment
is an angel a real compliment is loving
somebody even though you see them avatar
style
i see you
i see your julie
i see all of it and i still want to have
pajama movie night you know what i mean
i love you because you're perfect that
how about i love you even though i know
you had a panic attack at macaroni grill
for ordering the wrong entree how about
that
how about i still love you even though i
know you took a 15-minute cry break in
the ladies room because you should have
got the eggplant parm how about that
isn't that true love
how about i love you even though last
night i watched you playing grand theft
auto and you helped a lady you saw
getting mugged which is nice but then
when you returned her purse and she
didn't give you a reward i saw you run
her over with your car
even though that's red flag sociopathic
behavior
let's make spoons and fall asleep on
each other that's intimacy that's a
compliment i want and yes that's
something i really did in the game
50 bucks i saved you 500.
but that's true i mean think about it a
thoughtless like love you babe like with
no thought love bib
that's like giving someone a candle for
their birthday
are you listening a candle
from yankee candle
the thoughtless gift superstore
just a gift that screams i don't know
you as well as you thought i did
every candle should come with a card
that says hey you like flickering light
and mild aromas probably
happy anniversary from just another
faceless stranger
i'll admit it's a weird monologue it
started with divorce and fault and ended
with yankee candle